accueillir Patrick canner le chef de fil
des socialistes qui va s'installer à
votre place et qui va pouvoir nous
donner son sentiment sur ce vote puisque
vous l'avez vécu sur notre antenne 193
pour 114 contre le Sénat à adopté les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire bonjour Patrick Canet
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
une réaction sur ce vote écoutez deux
voix de moins encore pour la majorité
ils étaient à 195 ils sont aujourd'hui à
193 c'est bon c'est pas c'est pas majeur
mais c'est pas inintéressant ça montre
que le texte n'est vraiment pas
totalement consensuel c'est moi qu'on
puisse dire au sein de la majorité
sanatoriale donc c'est à suivre on va
analyser le vote des uns et les autres
c'est intéressant public donc on aura le
détail exactement de ce que chaque
sénateur a pu faire dans l'hémicycle au
moment du vote et donc si on verra qui
est-ce qui c'est effectivement qui a
changé de vote entre samedi dernier et
maintenant ça c'est au moins l'intérêt
du shooting public c'est qu'on sait qui
vote quoi ça il y a aussi le fait de
ralentir les débats pour la gauche
naturelle peut-être en tout cas nous
nous on va regarder de très près ce qui
va se passer à l'Assemblée parce que si
un 49-3 là on ne sait pas ce qui se
passe on ne sait pas qui vote quoi
c'était ma question est-ce que vous
voyez dans cette évolution du vote au
fur et à mesure de la réforme des
retraites une fébrilité de la part DLR
qui dénoterait ce qui va se jouer et qui
permettrait de comprendre ce qui va se
jouer cet après-midi et je ne suis pas
membre de l'exécutif mais ce vote ce
matin au Sénat que certains auraient pu
espérer plus large en faveur de la
réforme mais ce n'est pas le cas donc ça
peut interpeller effectivement le
président Macron parce que ça montre
tout simplement que il y a des LR qui ne
veulent pas mettre leur nom sur cette
réforme le présent République a qui
réunit les dirigeants de la majorité
présidentielle à midi à l'Elysée après
l'avoir fait ce matin à 8h15 qu'est-ce
que ça dit là encore que c'est et bien
vers ce déclenchement de 49-3 c'est vers
cela qu'on va c'est une fébrilité de la
part de l'exécutif moi je ne suis pas
dans l'exécutif naturellement mais
réunir les dirigeants un peu en
catastrophe c'est pas prévu initialement
ça veut dire très simplement très
simplement que aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron doute encore de sa capacité à
pouvoir faire passer par les voies
normales ce texte donc encore une fois
il y a sur lequel il y a une opposition
majeure dans le pays donc on se retrouve
devant un exécutif qui est daumur dans
les cordes et un petit peu sonné je le
pense s'il y a un 49-3 cet après-midi
Patrick caner qu'est-ce que vous appelez
à faire qu'est-ce que le gouvernement
doit faire le 49-3 est conceptionnel
dont acte la gauche tu as utilisé mais
avoir adopté le texte au Sénat avec un
44,3 votre bloqué un 49-3 le grand votre
bloqué ça pose un vrai problème ça pose
un vrai problème sur une réforme qui
touche quand même des millions de nos
concitoyens je le dis Manuel Valls vous
l'avez dit à utiliser 49-3 mais là on
touche à la vie à la vie des gens dans
ce pays et c'est quand même très
différent si un 49-3 ça signifie dépôt
d'une motion par la gauche qu'est-ce qui
va se passer encore une fois il y aura
d'émotions séparées différents groupes
de la gauche va déposer une motion oui
bien sûr si un 49-3 d'ailleurs même 149
francs on pourrait déposer une motion
c'est tout ça fait possible mais je
tiens à dire que jamais jamais il n'y
aura de signature commune d'une motion
avec l'extrême droite et qu'elle doit
être l'étape d'après c'est ma dernière
question est-ce qu'on peut imaginer une
dissolution dans les prochaines semaines
là vous me posez des questions qu'il
faut c'est la menace un peu le président
de la sur le Parlement c'est l'arme
lourde c'est le chantage permanent
aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des députés moi ce
que je sais c'est ce que nous allons
faire et il est fort probable que nous
ayons l'envie de demander au peuple ce
prononcer au travers peut-être dans un
référendum d'initiative partagée et bien
sur un ça serait fait un dame
d'initiative partagée ou RIP que la
gauche va déposer les trois groupes de
gauche vous allez déposer comme on
l'avait vu sur l'aéroport de Paris et ça
avait marché et ça avait fonctionné
alors il y avait eu le covid aussi qui
avait peut-être compliqué la donne pour
pour l'exécutif merci Patrick Kanner de
cette de cette réaction micro
[Musique]